in many remote Alaskan towns this is
just ordinary life
[Music]
Zack welcome back hey how you doing Bret
pretty good so you've got a story this
week that sounds like it's gonna be
pretty awesome you found this small town
in Alaska and this is a place that was
already pretty remote and cut off from
civilization and now even more so tell
us a little bit what you've learned here
yeah so you know almost everyone the
lower 48 states has had some kind of
run-in with a supply chain issue at this
point whether it's you know you go to
the store and you can't find eggs you
can't find milk in many remote Alaskan
towns this is just ordinary life so I
was curious to look at a place where the
supply chain is so ordinarily
complicated that any extra rent she
throw into the equation is almost
devastating and there are some people
finding really intuitive workarounds to
these issues this little town that we
chose to look at Gustavus Alaska
population 400 it's a place where there
was no electricity until 1985 no cell
phones until the mid 1900s
last night I joined a town hall meeting
by by telephone and there were five
people on the call so and that was
considered a monumental turnout for the
town so that's a quorum so this this
town usually gets its it there's one
grocery store in town and typically
they'll get their groceries by ferry you
can't get to this town by automobile the
only way you can get there is by plane
or airplane or by plane or boat so for
instance if you wanted to get there from
San Francisco you would fly to Seattle
you'd fly to Juneau Alaska
and then you take a little seaplane from
maybe a six seater seaplane from Juneau
to Gustavus problem is that a few months
ago that ferry went out of commission
the state had a bunch of budget cuts the
town is almost entirely dependent on
tourism revenue so a lot of things just
hit the fan at the same time and this
grocery store owner had to find a new
way to supply his town with not only
groceries but rations supplies the local
businesses also depended on him to bring
over things like lumber and concrete so
he bought his own barge $200,000 ship
and started making trips six and a half
hours one way between Gustavus and
Juneau Alaska to the Costco there which
is actually the smallest cost in the
United States and bought $20,000 worth
of stuff at a time and he's doing these
shipments once a week and basically
feeling his entire town on those trips
so not every town has such an altruistic
person who's willing to put the town on
his back and and shoulder that sort of
burden but this is just not some
ordinary good citizen this is somebody
who has pretty deep roots in this place
and you're telling me a little bit about
his is was it his grandfather can you
can you describe this this little
backstory I thought that was fascinating
yeah so his family goes way back in this
town to 1917 his great-grandfather's
name was Abraham Lincoln Parker his
father's name is Lee Parker and his
name's Lane Parker comes from a long
lineage of gustavus descendants and like
many people in the town he he his family
probably went up there to seek a kind of
a remote lifestyle it's it's a very
beautiful place it's right next to
Glacier Bay National Park which is just
a tremendous place but the
that remoteness and isolation sometimes
comes with a cost you're at the very end
of the supply chain before he started
his store there a gallon of milk in
Gustavus was twelve dollars so you know
you'd you'd buy it
you'd get it and yeah the shipping
company would get it in Seattle for like
three bucks then they'd have to like
load it onto the barge they'd have to
ship it on this ridiculous journey
across the ocean and all cost considered
by the time it got there the mark-up
would be like seven eight dollars so
this guy basically found a more
efficient way to minimize those
logistics and reduce the cost a little
bit on those Goods so abraham lincoln
parker would probably proud well the
other thing that interests me here is
this is not just about one remote town
in a remote place but it's it's really
more story about the supply chain
problems that many towns in rural
america are going to start to face as
this pandemic stretches out beyond the
coverage areas there's like a lot of
people and what they're what we're
reading in the pages of lots of
newspapers and magazines so there was
somebody who talked to it was a kansas
state university who sort of shed light
on some of the effect that we're gonna
see in rural towns can you tell us a
little bit about that yeah this is like
kind of an extreme example of remote or
rural town this place in Alaska but
there are plenty of towns small
municipalities in the United States like
in places like Kansas where there are
one there's one grocery store in town
and in a lot of these places a lot of
these places are so small that it
doesn't even make sense for a Walmart or
a dollar store to come and crouch on the
business there so the the grocery store
is is on its own and a lot of time a lot
of these owners are very old
they've been into town for a long time
there are kind of a town fixture and
when they retire they have trouble
having someone to fill their shoes
finding someone to fill their shoes so a
lot
these grocery stores closed people are
in a situation where they have to
commute 30 or 40 minutes to the next
town or the next grocery store over to
get their stuff and especially with
koban 19 right now when people are
shelter in place that's not a
possibility for a lot of people aside
from that you know the population who
doesn't have access to cars or who isn't
mobile for any reason so it's a big
issue
we could see coronavirus having a pretty
devastating impact on rural towns with a
single grocery store like this and and
even big shipping logistics companies
freight companies will sometimes bypass
these talents because this really makes
sense to stop there so these towns are
having to find ways to rely on local
economies and farmers ranchers things
like that to fill the void but sometimes
even that's not enough
so in tandem with coronavirus we're
seeing this great ongoing decline of
rural grocery stores that many people
are trying to find a solution to it's
fascinating well more on Sunday
definitely open Zak's email and if you
have stories of supply chain disruptions
you want to share then send them to
holler at the hustle and we'll
definitely take a look because we're
continuing to find these stories
interesting and want to continue to
cover those undiscovered stories for you
all right thanks for joining a sack and
everybody open your email and Sunday for
more take care of one
[Music]
you